[موسيقى]
في فتره من حياتي كنت
وكان عندي رهاب
اجتماعي وما كنت قعدت ثلاث سنين ما بطلع
من البيت نشر لي ما بطلع من البيت كان
عندي كمان افكار انتهاريه كتير هذا الشيء
كان بسبب انه انا كتير تعرضت للتنمر
[موسيقى]
هي عباره عن حركات لا اراديه نفس ما شفته
او في الجسم وفي انواع ثانيه الحركات
متعدده كثير شوي متشعبه وفيها تفاصيل
عديده فممكن في اشياء انا ما اعرف اشرحها
لانه هي ما بيفهمها الا الشخص نفسه بسبب
عمق تفاصيلها
فالاشي اللي انا عم بعمله حاليا هو له
علاقه باني اساعد الناس تفهم اكثر عن طريق
لانه حبيت اني انا اكون مكان هدول الاشخاص
وافهم انا لو كنت مكانهم شفت شخص كمان
بيعمل سكس ايش ممكن يفطر على بالي وخصوصا
فئه الاطفال لانه انا اغلب التنمر تكون
قطعت له كان من فئه الاطفال صح انه في
فئات عمريه تانيه لكن وانا طفله التركيز
الاكبر على الاطفال لانه هم ما عندهم قدره
انهم يفهموا ايش يعني فانا بحاول اخلي
الاهالي يعلموهم انه انهم مشترك انهم
يتقبلوا الاختلاف بشكل عام وتحديات بشكل
عام في اوقات كتير انتو كنتو تسالوني انه
ليه ما تحاولي تقنع حركاتك او ايش ممكن
يصير لو انت منعتي الحركه بتطلع اكثر شيء
بيسالوني عن الناس او بيهتموا يعرفوا انا
كيف بتعامل مع واقع حياتي مع الحركات
الاراديه يعني بيسالوني كيف مثلا بعمل ميك
اب كيف بنام احيانا بيسالوني انا كيف باكل
مثلا كيف بطلع اماكن شو بتعامل مع الناس
بس سوشيال ميديا ساعدتني اكثر باني اوصل
هاي الاصوات كلها حتى الجانب الثاني اصوات
مرتين ترك نفسهم والوطن العربي ما في ما
في اي مؤسسه او اي مركز او اي مستشفى او
اي جمعيه او اي شيء له علاقه في حتى
الاطباء نادر ما تلاقي طبيب فاهم كل طبعا
هذا مش قصور بالشخص نفسه لكن عنا التعليم
فيها شوي ضعيف انا حاليا اعد من الاولى
بالاردن اللي عم تطلع تعمل طب ليه اكيد في
غيري في الاردن لكن هم مش قادرين يعلوا
صوتهم
هلا انا بشوف انه مستوى الوعي الحالي
بال2023 اعلى بكثير من المستوى الوعي
السابق ومتلازمه تورث لانه هلا السوشيال
ميديا ما ما خلت مجال لحدا انه ما يعرف صح
انه التنمر عم بيخف لكن الوعي الطبي ما عم
بيزيد في موضوع صرت صراحه فانا اتمنى اننا
نوصل لمرحله حتى الاطباء اللي هم يفهموا
كل شيء عنه